god is good
and all the time
psalm 100 5 for the lord is good his mercy
is everlasting and his truth endureth to all
generations who is with us now for the first
time today merge your hand first time today
you weren't here earlier god bless you thank
you for coming anyone else first time today
is that a handbag there god bless ah god bless
you god bless you what church are you from that
somebody shouted
tonga the tongan church where is that
in tonga okay all right thank you where
oh los angeles all right god bless you my dear
friends god bless you and those of you with us
for the first time thank you very much for joining
us it is now uh about three minutes after eight
i will not hold you long you've had a long
day and the bible says let your moderation
be known unto all men be temperate
in all things that includes preaching
before i begin would you
kindly turn your phones off
a few years ago i was in a certain country on
the face of the earth preaching and i we were
having the service in a theater seats sloping
right down to the pit and i was preaching and
the lady right in the front her phone rang she
reached into her bag pulled it out and talked
right in my face for about three minutes if my
recollection is reliable then she hung up put it
in her bag and resumed listening to the message
and so that was the height of disrespect for god
you cannot carry one of these in a courtroom
and if you sneaked one in and it rang
we would visit you through the department of
prison ministries and so we're asking you to
show respect for god and turn these things off
until they are dead let me set the example for you
while i'm asking you to do that let's see all
right my phone is off the second favor i request
is that you pray for me while i speak and you
simply say lord put your words in that man's mouth
in exodus chapter 4 verse 12 god said to moses
now therefore go and i will be with thy mouth and
teach thee what thou shall say and i want god to
talk to me as he answers your prayers on my behalf
and faith number three i want you to think as
you listen let's pray our father in heaven we bow
in your presence dear god because we have no one
else to whom we can turn we come their god because
you've invited us to come boldly to the throne of
grace hebrews 4 16. we come asking first of all to
forgive our sins dear god if we've done anything
to offend your divine sensibilities forgive us
grant us your grace dear god grant us your spirit
soften our hearts their father that the world may
foil upon soil that is rich and in which the
seed of the world might grow use me their god
for your glory speak clearly through me i pray
bless every man woman boy and girl in jesus name
i pray let god's people say with me amen and
amen one other question who is with us who is
not a seventh adventist we know this jasmine this
morning there was monika where what's your name
who d-a-w-n sister dawn god bless you
god bless you god bless you anyone else
you are not a seventh-day adventist you have
gracious with your presence just raise your hand
all right the bible let's go to our
scripture reading revelation 14 6-12
revelation 14 6-12
do you have that
and i saw another angel fly in the midst
of heaven having the everlasting gospel to
preach unto them that dwell on the earth
and to every nation kindred tongue and
people saying with a loud voice pick it up
with me now fear god and give glory to him
for the hour of his judgment is come and worship
him that made heaven and earth and the seas
and the fountains of waters now this angel
the bible says having the everlasting gospel
which means this gospel which was god's
response to the possibility of sin
and the actuality of sin was designed developed
and devised by the father and the son way back
i mean way back in this council of
peace between the father and the son
this plan called the gospel was
developed before adam and eve were made
since christ was a core creator of the
gospel if i may say that he and the father
came up with this plan no one on earth could
preach the gospel more clearly than christ
am i close to speaking the truth not even that
mighty evangelist called the apostle paul no one
could preach the gospel more clearly
than the one who developed the gospel
jesus christ my question to you is when
jesus preached the gospel what did he say
he said many things but does the bible contain
in the words of christ a summary statement
of the gospel go to the book of matthew
chapter three you shall read from verse one
our subject watch and pray it's
also our theme what book did i say
what chapter what verses one or two now we're not
looking at jesus we're looking at the forerunner
of jesus what was his name john the baptist
in those days came john the baptist into the
wilderness of judea preaching and saying
repenting for the kingdom of what heaven
is at hand now here is a summary statement
of the preaching of john the baptist
what did john the baptist say repent
why the kingdom of heaven is at hand
what's that big word in that message repent
let's look at what jesus said
the very next chapter matthew 4 we shall
read verse 17 our subject watch and pray
from that time began jesus to preach
and to say that's matthew 4 17
repent for the kingdom of heaven is at
hand notice the wording from that time jesus
began to preach and to say what do
you understand by from that time
and from that time and onward
jesus said repent
let's go to mark chapter one
mark second book of the second gospel shortest
gospel mark was not one of the twelve disciples
neither was luke mark one what verses
that i say okay verses 14 and 15
of mark chapter one you're listening now
after that john was put in prison jesus
came into galilee preaching the gospel
of the kingdom of god and saying what
the time is fulfilled and the kingdom of what
god is at hand repent ye and believe the gospel
now jesus said repent john the baptist
said repent let's go to matthew 10.
in matthew 10 jesus sends
the 12 disciples to preach
what did he tell them to say let's read verse 7
what does verse 7 say as he go what preach saying
the kingdom of heaven is at hand now the word
repent does not appear but we have to include it
so jesus said repent john the baptist
before him said repent when christ sent
the twelve disciples he said preach and say
repent for the kingdom of heaven is at hand
why repent
but when you tell someone repent the
person has to understand repent of what
what is that sin what is sin
transgression of the law what
is the law the transcript of god's
righteous character the standard by
which character is measured the standard
by which admission to heaven is determined
and so to preach repentance effectively one
must answer the question what is sin what is
the law what is righteousness what is repentance
they cannot be repentance without confession
and so the word repent brings in the central
elements of the gospel the law righteousness sin
when jesus said repent if you
were listening in that audience
would you turn to the person next to you and
say did you hear what he said he said you repent
how would you have taken the message
personally now our theme is watch and pray are
you with me has anyone said lord put your words in
that man's mouth yet anyone said that god bless
you and your family and grant you an abundant
entrance into his kingdom for those of you
rebelling please change your mind and pray for me
when the message was delivered
repent it was personal
watch and pray when we read watch and pray for
you know not what our the son of man cometh
we start watching the illuminati
then we watch the pope
then we watch the international monetary fund
then we watch the world bank
and we watch natural disasters
do you know god isn't waiting for the pope
to do anything in order for him to come
i lost you
i lost you the coming of christ is not
dependent on what the illuminati does or do
jesus said and this gospel of the kingdom shall
be preached in all the world for a witness unto
all nations finish the verse then shall they
come this has nothing to do with the illuminati
or the world bank
or who's in the white house
or number 10 downing street
christ is waiting with longing desire
for the manifestation of himself
in his people when the character of god
shall be perfectly reproduced in his people
then he will come to claim them as his own not
when the illuminati has done enough illuminating
are you with me is that a word whether this
or not i just made a word that's not what god
is waiting for or looking at god's focus
has always been what are my people doing
every miracle in the bible was either
directly for or on behalf of the israelites
every nation that enters the bible is named
only as that nation has any interaction with
god's people otherwise says every ray of light the
world has ever received came through god's people
when god destroyed the egyptian army he destroyed
that army for his people when he destroyed the
canaanites in judges chapter four he destroyed
the canaanites for his people when he sent saul
to wipe out the amalekites for his people when
he sent a destroying angel to kill 185 000 men
of the army of sennacherib it was for god's people
the bible says he rebuked kings for their sakes
god's eye is on what we're doing
it is not the illuminati
that is dissing ellen white
ah you turned me off again
let me use a better word this thing is too much
of a street word okay it is not the illuminati
that is undermining the influence of ellen
white in the church it is the church now not
necessarily the church official let me say that
before a letter comes from the general conference
distancing themselves from me i'll do it myself
i am not saying the official church undermines
ellen white but elements of the church it is
not the world bank that is attacking the sabbath
it is not the international monetary
fund that says the holy ghost is energy
we are the ones who do that
and so when we consider watch and pray let us
take some time stop looking at the illuminati
just for a while or the pope or the world bank
or the middle east or southeastern asia or canada
or tonga let us look at ourselves now listen to
jesus christ as he speaks to the disciples the
bible says in matthew 26 verse 40 and then jesus
cometh to the disciples and findeth them sleeping
and safe and to peter what could
you not watch with me one hour
now verse 41 go there matthew 26 verse 41 our
subject watch and pray 20 minutes after 8.
you have matthew 26 reading verse 41. have you
found it read it with me watch and pray that you
are enter not into temptation the spirit indeed
is willing but the flesh is weak look at those
words again let us read microscopically
make sure you're focusing not distracted
jesus said watch and pray why
that he enter not into temptation
there is a difference between entering
into temptation and being tempted
no amount of watching and praying
can prevent you from being tempted
you're shaking your head
politely but you missed it
let's be honest in the presence
of a holy god what did i just say
no amount of watching and praying
can prevent you from being tempted
jesus was tempted temptation is a hazard of living
on this sinful earth by the way temptation is not
a sin but entering into temptation that's entirely
different that has nothing to do with the devil
it has entirely to do with me
when i put myself in situations
that exposed me to spiritual danger and the
devil was somewhere else doing his business
let me uh try to explain
a lady calls up the pastor
pastor i need bible studies
but i'm a flight attendant and my hours are
crazy but i'll be free 11 o'clock tonight
i need a study on purity
so he's a soul winner so he jumps into his
prius off he goes when he gets this 11 45
the angels are sleeping
now do you understand what i'm saying
the woman is single he's single and
that is entering into temptation
the devil had nothing to do with it
so jesus says watch and pray that ye do not walk
into situations that endanger your spiritual life
now let me identify one danger
that endangers imperils our spiritual lives
in colossians chapter 3 let's go there 8 25
colossians 3 let's read from verse one
have you found colossians
who wrote colossians all right very good
who wrote acts okay colossians 3 reading
from verse 1. the bible says how many of you
have the king james version makes your hands
read with me if he then be risen with christ
seek those things which are where above
stop what do you understand by seek
is it a casual look it's
an application of the mind
a pursuit if he then be risen with christ
what does it mean to be risen with christ
what does christ raise you from death of sin and
you hath he quickened who are dead in trespasses
and sin ephesians two verse one if he then be
risen with christ through conversion you're
now in christ seek those things which are above
where christ sitteth on the right hand of whom
god verse 2 read it with me set your affections
on things above not on things of this world stop
this is where we enter into temptation
our affections are on things of this world
and jesus says where your treasure is finish
the verse there will your heart be also and
god is settled and burdened with the church in
which perhaps the overwhelming majority of the
members are focused on this life let me give you a
quotation by the way last night i gave a quotation
the sheep's clothing seems so
real and genuine remember that
don't recall where i said it was from but it's
from faith and works page 45 paragraph one
sometimes you've got to correct yourself now
reviewing herald january 24 1888 paragraph four
listen to this troubling statement if your
thoughts your plans your purposes are all
directed toward the accumulation of the things
of earth your anxiety your study your interests
will all be centered upon the world the heavenly
attractions will lose their beauty the glories of
the eternal world will cease to have the force
of reality to you your heart will be with your
treasure and every faculty of your mind will be
concentrated on the work that you have chosen
every faculty of your mind concentrated on the
work that you have chosen so that you will not
heed the warnings and entreaties
of the word and spirit of god
you will have no time to devote to study
of the scriptures and earnest prayer to
escape the snares of satan and to render
intelligent obedience to your heavenly father
long quotation let's summarize it ella
white is saying if your focus is this world
you will eventually arrive at the place
where heaven is no more real than star trek
going to church but no concept of the life to come
you see your mind must be either rooted in heaven
or rooted in the earth there is not a
middle ground you can't have your mind
stuck somewhere on mars it's either rooted on
the earth or rooted in heaven the bible says
let your mind be focused based above this does
not mean that your earthly life immediately
collapses the earthly life has meaning only
as it is lived from the context of heaven
we must see things the way god sees things
you heard the words you missed
the meaning let me say it again
when samuel went to anoint a king to replace
saul elia the first boy came when samuel
saw him he said surely the lord's anointed is
before him now samuel was the only other person
beside jesus christ who was prophet priest
and king of course in his day it wasn't king
was judge only christ held all three offices
beside samuel this first of the great prophets
following a way of thinking alien to god he
looked on the outside he said this guy's 6-3
nicely built broad-shouldered designer
outfit he must be the one now david
was such an unlikely selection of possibility
that jesse did not even invite him into the house
when samuel came to a night jesse called seven
boys left david with the sheep in other words
for jesse there is nowhere in the world god
could have chosen david but god chose david
noah had three boys shem ham and japheth
if you read the order of the names
you'll assume shem was the oldest the oldest
was japheth then shem then ham god's choice
to be the father of the
holy line was shem not jesus
isaac had two boys esau and
jacob from the womb god's choice
was jacob norris or god does
not function the way we function
the father of abraham had three boys abraham
nehor and hiran if you look at the order of the
names you think abraham was the oldest
he was the youngest but god chose the
youngest as the one through whom the line would
continue god does not think the way we think
and so god says for my thoughts are not
your thoughts neither are your ways my way
saith the lord for as the heavens are higher
than the earth you tell me how high that is
so are my ways higher than your ways and my
thoughts than your thoughts whether it's education
romance finance uh friends socializing recreation
church service we must see things the way god does
because if we don't we violate amos chapter
3 verse 3 can two walk together finish the
verse except if you agreed now here
is god put him on the right side
here are we in order for us to
walk together somebody has to move
are you listening to me here's god that's the
heavenly way here are we that's the sinful
fallen way now god says to walk together
we have to be agreed who agrees with whom
we must agree with god somebody say a man for
god too often we try to get god to agree with us
and so we change the standards of the bible
to bring god in line with our corrupt thinking
you understand we bring god to see things our
way now the only thing that happens when
god sees things our way is that god pukes
according to revelation he
spews us out of his mouth
jesus said lay not up for yourselves
treasure upon earth where moth
and rust doth corrupt and with thieves break
through and steal but lay up for yourselves
treasured in heaven with neither moth nor
rust that corrupt and where thieves do not
break through and steal now here is a powerful
statement from christ for where your treasure is
they will your heart be also if all your money
is in your education not in the work of god
your mind will not be this
way your mind will be this way
if all your time is for earthly pursuits
that's an investment your heart will be
where you have invested your resources
why is the work of god not advancing
well people always ask me why don't
you have a ministry i don't want one
i am my ministry
and one of the reasons i don't want a ministry
the church is i don't want to say overrun
but the church has so many ministries
and christ hasn't come so we just have
more ministries and it hasn't come
now i pray for ministries don't misunderstand
me i pray for certain ministries by name
i pray for on secrets and sealed
words elderberry sister eileen
i pray for 3abn i pray for adtv i pray for
africa alive i pray for gyc i pray for ministries
but i'm also realizing the more we keep
multiplying ministries nothing's happening
where is our mind my brother
my sister where is your mind
a man said to jesus master i will
follow you let me go and bury my father
you know the story what did jesus say to that man
do you know how hard that is
now i refer to that to make this point
when we truly commit to the cause of god
other members of the church will look at us and
describe us as harsh unfeeling cold insensitive
jesus heard that john the baptist was in prison
what was the relationship between christ and john
the baptist they were cousins you would have
thought christ would have rushed to the prison
guard them out christ just left
the area and left him in prison
you know why getting john out had nothing to do
with the ministry of christ or the mission nothing
christ was on the cross he
looked and saw his mother
he looked at john jesus had four half-brothers
he gave his mother to john not his brothers
jesus at his resurrection he opened the tomb
people came up he took them to heaven with him
left his mother clearly god
does not think the way we think
now if i were going back to heaven i'd take my
mother i may leave my father but i take my mother
you know you watch television and these
sports shows and the athletes hi mom
i've never heard one say hi dad it's always
hi mom i would take my jesus left his mother
it had nothing to do clearly with
his mission taking he didn't take her
we need to think like god
in other words the mission of god takes
precedence over everything and everyone
who was i talking to earlier was it dr tim or
somebody when god told abraham to kill isaac
yes sister do you think he told
sarah it wasn't sarah's business
god didn't talk to sarah god spoke to
abraham by the way when god speaks to you act
just make sure it is god speaking to you and so
abraham acted no consultation with sarah i'm not
preaching independent action i am preaching taking
god at his word and putting god's mission first
so jesus says watch and pray that he enter not
into temptation one of our greatest dangers
is that we are so concerned with surviving this
life we don't realize we're making no investment
in the life to come now this life lasts this long
are you with me the life to come lasts this long
but we concentrate all our energies in this life
i have nothing against education but jesus
didn't die so people can have more degrees
i have nothing against marriage christ didn't
die because people couldn't find spouses
i have nothing against wealth but
christ didn't die to make people
rich by the way poverty is not a sin if it
were sin christ would be sinner number one
christ didn't die because someone had a
social need christ died because of sin
yours finished my words and mine
it's no wonder then that jesus
said repent it is a message of love
christ is telling us there is
something destroying your life
stop what is this saying father sin here is the
man walking to quicksand somebody else says stop
that's a command of love stop this suicidal
behavior repent and so we need to watch ourselves
where is my life headed in the past five years
have i grown in grace have i can i defend the
teachings of this church can i explain the state
of the dead can i defend the sanctuary doctrine
what have i been doing in the church for 50 years
and i still need to call the
pastor to explain baptism
and i'm supposed to watch the
illuminati no i need to watch
me i need to step back and
say what's going on in my life
why am i not blessed because my
mind is on the earth not in heaven
why am i not blessed because
god's business is not my priority
why am i not blessed because i'm a
child of satan who goes to church
my brothers and sisters we need to watch
and pray don't watch people watching
people is not a spiritual gift
rebuking others is sometimes a necessity yes
it is not us by the way i also tell people
casting out demons is not a spiritual gift
so don't go looking for demons to cast out
before you know it someone may have
to come and cast the demon out of you
let's watch where will we watch ourselves
let's pray what will we pray about
ourselves what is there in my life a sin
that has run through my life like a
red thread through a white garment
what has baffled me and bedeviled me and
hounded my steps all my christian life
and i cannot break this thing listen to me you
don't need a million sins to be lost you need one
how many did adam commit before
he was cast out of the garden one
and it doesn't have to be a biggie
father what is there in my life and if you embark
upon this watch and pray your eyes and my eyes are
not good enough to see the faults we've got to
pray what david prayed he said search me your
god know my heart try me and know my thoughts and
see see what if there be any wicked way in me and
god will find something and lead me in the way
what everlasting that's the object of our watch
and prayer leave the illuminati
alone for a while give them a break
leave the pope alone
look at your life gork forgive the person who
hurts you go apologize to the person you hurt
go pay the money you borrow and
then you left town do i look angry
you know i'm a nice man say amen i really am
but i the carnal nature will
focus on every subject exact self
watch and pray tonight i want you to make a
decision if it appeals to you if it applies to you
there's something in your life you must change
identify that thing and make that commitment
tonight that one thing will take you to hell
and it does not have to be mass murder suicide
genocide bank robbery hijacking cars
it can be as simple as no bible study
it can be as simple as too busy to pray
it can be as simple as i want such a high
lifestyle i need the tithe to support it
you didn't hear me i have chosen a
lifestyle and i need the tithe to support it
it may be every church board meeting
you are the cause of the trouble
identify that thing and tonight let's present
other god and say father here is the cancer
by the work of your spirit cut it out
it may be you are romantically involved
with someone outside of the church
and if that's the case break it off tonight
call him it's usually the women call him
i am telling you what i've seen nine out of ten
times it's a woman outside of the church call him
and tell him god spoke to your heart you
were wrong you misled him into thinking the
church tolerates that the church does not
an adventist minister is not authorized to
marry an advocate and a non-adventist
he can marry a baptist and a lutheran
he can marry uh something or something he
is not authorized to marry an
advocate and a non-adventist
if you study genesis 6 the chapter
that tells us the flood is coming
the only clearly identified
sin was mixed marriages
notice i clearly identified mixed marriages
you don't believe me read enoch and seth
alawite's chapter and patriots and prophets
nimrod was a product of one of those marriages
and you know better than imran
why was it the temple could not be
built in the days of ezra or nehemiah
because there were mixed marriages
that may be what you need to confess if you're
already married but if you're not break it off
tonight when you call him you're not calling
to discuss you're calling to announce
young lady spoke to me uh in a
certain city on the face of the earth
and she uh she said pastor pray for
me no prayer for my boyfriend and i
said pray for your boyfriend why he won't
come to church so i said why want a good
70 advertised vegetarian not come to church
and she put her head down what do you think
she said he is not a seventy i said oh
i said what do you want me to
pray and say and i was serious
well the lord would touch his heart i said
let me tell you what i'll pray and say
that you will apologize to him for
misleading him for giving him depression
any man can walk into the adventist church and get
one you apologize to him after apologizing to god
and then you leave him to god
she put her head down walked away
what is that one thing you and i need to separate
from let's identify it let's leave it at the foot
of the cross tonight for some of us it may
be your relationship with christ has been
so stale like brenda's been on the self since
1944 so still that you need to start with god
all over again i was in south korea it's
a nice story so i'll identify the country
i made an appeal for baptism
re-baptism 50-something people came
and i met with him and a
retired pastor met with me
and he told a story that really amazed me he
said in the middle of his ministry he realized
he was not growing in grace his experience
was you know what you call flat lining you
medical experts flat lining not a blip just and
anything is like this you know it's really this
because it's either that or that there's
no such thing as this spiritually
and so he went to the conference president
he said mr president i want to be re-baptized
but naturally being a human being the conference
president's mind went straight into the gutter
what did you do which is what's the
sister's name he said no mr president no no
my walk with christ has become so stale there
has been no growth i need to start all over again
i need to be rematched the president said
okay we'll baptize you at night he said no
baptize me in front of the church
that the members who are also in a similar
predicament may feel the need to be re-baptized
ellen white writes an evangelism piece 375
paragraph two when a soul is truly reconverted
let that soul be re-baptized i was preaching
a certain country on the face of the earth
the pastor's wife got re-baptized and
his son and he re-baptized both of them
i was in another city on the face
of the earth not far from here
the youth pastor got re-baptized listen
to me there are some of us who need to
get back into the water and
start with god all over again
and this time do it right and so watch and prayer
where will you watch what will you pray about me
is there someone who will say father there's
something in my life i need to give up
by the power of your spirit and the blood of your
son i lay that thing down at your feet if there's
someone who'll say that can i see your hands
seriously there is something if you raise your
hand stand up there if you didn't raise your hand
don't stand there is something i need to let go
it may be i work too much
temperance covers every area of the life
what's the appeal there is something i need to
let go as i watch myself and i pray for my own
salvation because the closer and the more right
i am with god the more effectively god can use me
so this is not selfishness this is
preparation to be used effectively
appeal number two there's someone who perhaps
has decided i need to be baptized or re-baptized
i need to be baptized or re-baptized
my heart has been touched i've been convicted i
need to take this step and the spirit is gently
pushing me to take that step is there someone who
is convicted to be baptized or re-baptized let me
see your hand baptize come come don't be afraid
come baptizers are re-baptized raise your hand
or just come come my brother come come i am come
come come come come if you raise your hand come
bring the little boy with you come i am convicted
to be baptized or re-baptized come somebody put a
seat right there for my brother who's coming
put a chair right here for him thank you
i really need to be baptized or re-baptized
come there must be somebody else
come don't be cool hell is not cool come i
really need to make a decision to be baptized
or re-baptized let's all come to the same place
come over here come over here please come over
here i need someone to come and take names anyone
else something has happened in my heart god is
speaking to me he will not speak forever i am
convicted i need to be baptized re-baptized come
the rest of you should be praying come quickly
five minutes to nine we've all had a long day
i need to be baptized or re-baptized come
i won't delay you along i promise
anyone else anyone else my brothers and sisters
do everything in your power to
see the face of god when he comes
elohim says we have a heaven to gain and a
hell to shun let us shun hell by our lifestyles
i give you 60 seconds and i pray you have been
touched convicted by the spirit of god you know
you ought to be baptized or rebaptized come
60 seconds come come to god bless you sister
god bless you come you know in your
heart you ought to do it 45 seconds come
30 seconds i know in my heart based on the life
i've been living i need to start all over with god
i know that and god knows it
even more clearly come 20 seconds
20 10 seconds god bless you
sister from my heart god bless you
that's somebody coming over there come
come come god bless you god bless you
you know you can fool me you can fool yourself
who is it we cannot fool god cannot fool god
my brothers and sisters it is better to fall
on the rock than to have the rock fall on you
in other words it is better to stop than to have
god stop you my 60 seconds are up i have to pray
we also need your names this is very serious so
that we can do proper follow-up while i'm praying
you may feel free to come you will not interrupt
the prayer heads bowed eyes closed captioning not
their god in available we should be the
object of our watching more than anything else
because salvation is first so personal and for the
while we may deceive ourselves thinking we're fine
father we need to surrender to the conviction
of your spirit that tells us all is not well
we're wretched miserable poor blind and naked
and so they god i present you those who answer
the call for baptism of rebaptism in the name of
jesus christ who died for them in the name of
jesus who cannot lie and you cannot lie their
god i ask you to bless them now grant them your
spirit their god a measure of the spirit that
will sustain them to such a degree no pressure
from family or friends will change their minds
ah lord let them go with determination to that
pool as jesus went with determination to the cross
and for those who are still lingering their god in
mercy in love in desperate divine love move them
come as close as you can without forcing them
their god shove them a little farther why heads
about isaac closed for the last time who else will
come and say i want to be baptized or re-baptized
come 30 seconds come someone else come i really
need to be baptized or re-baptized come 30 seconds
just come if you're afraid tell the person next
you walk with you 20 seconds just leave your place
and come change your life you may never have
another opportunity like this you may attend
other services but never one just like this god
bless your sister give her a card ten seconds
baptism re-baptism a brand new start with god
here's a good brother somebody give him a card
father in heaven as i finish this
prayer do not finish your grace
as i end the prayer god do not end your mercy
one more time father bless those who responded
and please trouble those who are still resisting
father i mean it when i say give them no rest
until they make this decision and they will be
glad they did now they god as we leave let your
angels escort us to our destinations their god
keep us from harm and danger let us meditate
on what we've heard bring us back tomorrow for
the conclusion of this blessed week and i pray
take all the glory they god give us the blessing
in jesus name we pray let god's people say
amen and amen god bless you travel
safely make sure we've gotten your name
you